And so good morning to everyone coming over
or dialing in over from the East Coast of
the United States.
And good evening to the brave souls that are
dialing in from Europe.
So jack already introduced me, so I'm going
to skip this.
But today we're going to talk about standards.
And before
I go deeper into the particular use cases
in biomedical imaging, I'd like to talk a
bit more broadly about what
standards are.
So to begin with--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Well, if you haven't understood any of this,
this is probably because we have not been
using the same standard,
because if you look at a language as a form
of a standard, or in other words a standard
is a form of a language,
it's all about communicating.
It's all about finding the same level playing
field to be able to exchange ideas.
And
when we are able to do that, we are able to
build things together.
It's basically the essence of collaboration.
And languages, even though they usually evolve
over hundreds of years, are a form of a standard.
I subscribe to
you communicating with you using English.
And only because of that, you are able to
do this, because you have
also understood the rules of that language.
And even though languages evolve over time--
over, as I mentioned,
ages or millennia some of them actually have
been designed de novo, from scratch in other
words.
For example,
Esperanto, which is not an official language,
created 19-- sorry, 1870-- which was optimized
for how easy it should
be to pick it up and learn, which is just
a neat example of how people introduce artificial
standards in languages as
well.
But languages are not the only examples of
standard out there.
Probably each of you have a computer.
And that
computer has a platter of different parts
and connections you can plug into.
And this is another very common
occurrence of standards.
And those connections are industry, acknowledged,
approved way of communicating
between hardware.
And probably you recognize some of the parts
in this picture.
And this is how I can buy a piece
of hardware, for example a laptop, from one
manufacturer, and then buy a microphone or
a webcam from another
manufacturer, and plug one into another.
And those two manufacturers, they do not have
to work with each other
directly.
They just need to subscribe to the same language,
to the same way of exchanging information
by a
hardware connection.
And that's how all these different plaques
and parts come along.
And there are more examples, especially with
the hardware industry, where standardization
doesn't always go
that well.
For example, many of the laptops that are
coming out right now have this new, fancy
part, sometimes
referred to as USB C, sometimes referred to--
Thunderbolt 3.
And this part looks exactly the same, even
though it
could actually provide many different functionalities
that are not totally compatible.
So that also shows that even in
the industry hardware world, there is a need
for standards that are clean, as well as intuitive,
both for users and
the manufacturers.
We can go further.
For example, the way we deliver electricity
is another form of standardization that is
very
important.
So for any of you who traveled a little bit
outside of your country, you probably noticed
that the sockets
in the walls that deliver power have different
shapes.
And most of North America, it's a specific
standard from
NEMA.
And most of Europe is also subscribing to
a different standard.
And of course there's the UK that has to be
different.
But that's another way of benefiting from
doing one thing the same way, because if we
didn't have a
common way of delivering power to our appliances,
each manufacturer of appliance would have
to basically find
some sort of a deal with a power provider
or become the power provider itself, which
is preposterous.
And then we have digital communication, so
in other words the internet.
And that's another example where
agreeing on a common standard of communicating
and encapsulating information in packets allows
many
services built by different companies, that
sometimes outright compete with each other,
to operate on the same
layer and be able to communicate with each
other.
For example, both Bing and Google are using
the same
TCP/IP protocol to communicate with their
customers and with each other, even though
they're are at outright
competition.
And then we also have a higher level of digital
communication, the application programming
interfaces, or APIs.
This is the way how modern web applications
can be built very rapidly, and you can go
from prototype to a
scalable solution very quickly by using those
standardized ways of scheduling services and
receiving results from
a plethora of different things.
Right now, we have APIs for a very sophisticated
procedure, for example, detecting
faces from pictures or detecting mood of a
particular person from a recording of their
voice.
So this thing has been
flourishing a lot.
So you might ask how these standards actually
developed in the industry, how all these advantages
of having a
common language actually come about.
So in the industry, there are a few organizations
that try to help the
different industry players to start talking
with the same language.
One of them is the Institute of Electrical
and
Electronics Engineers, IEEE in other words,
which is known in some circles for publishing
engineering content.
But
one of the big things they do is working on
standards.
So one of the standards that they're very
famous for is Wi-Fi, or in other words 802.11,
which is an extension of
the 802 standard, which is just ethernet.
And that standard allows different appliances
to talk to each other
wirelessly.
And this standard was developed by EEE by
bringing different industry players into the
same process.
And IEEE has a process for deciding what should
be in the final standards.
And this process involve a draft that is
then refined, that is then voted upon.
And if it has enough votes, it's basically
becomes a standard.
And IEEE is acknowledging the role of different
players in the industry.
So here when it actually comes to voting in
many occasions, it's not people voting for
a standard, but particular key industry players
voting for what should be-
- in the standard and what should not.
Another example of a standardization body
is the World Wide Web Consortium.
So this one is very well known for
higher-level markup language that we use on
the internet almost everyday.
So coming from the very commonly
used HTML, which then became XHTML, through
styling-- such as CSS and Images like scale-vector
graphics--
all of these things where standards proposed
and working by the World Wide Web Consortium.
And right now they
enable web developers to build websites and
be relatively certain that those websites
will work and be rendered in
a similar way across different web browsers.
And those who did web development know that
actually adherence to those standards by different
web browsers
has been historically problematic.
And quite often there are some rough edges
that require developers to work
around certain problems, particular tools
that do not implement those standards very
well.
And World Wide Web Consortium also has a process,
and it also involves multiple drafts and release
candidates
that are either advanced to the next stage
or refined.
And these multiple levels of proposal is important
because
each time you elevate a particular proposal
to a new level, that rings a lot of bells,
and that promotes a lot of
players to contribute time and look at the
standard and basically-- it's basically a
signal saying hey, this will
become a standard soon.
You should have a look at it now before it's
too late to make any changes.
And then finally-- something much more relevant
to biomedical engineering-- there's the National
Electrical
Manufacturers Association, or NEMA, which
is not only famous for standardizing the electrical
plugs in the US, but
also for the DICOM standards, so digital imaging
and communications in medicine standard, which
is widely used
in clinical applications for storing and transferring
medical imaging data-- has been used for quite
a while.
I think
history reaches the 80s, and it has seen a
lot of revisions.
But it is widely adopted in different hospital
settings,
even though adherence to this standard is
sometimes not perfect, especially when it
comes to neuroimaging, and
even more when it comes to cutting edge research
neuroimaging.
But that's the industry.
And I want to talk a little bit more about
standards and context of research or in context
of
academia.
So your situation is slightly different, and
I would like to explain where are those differences
coming
from.
But before we actually go into the cultural
changes, I would like to point you to this
fantastic resource, this
website called fairsharing dot-org, which
allows you to search across different research
or academic standards
that are out there.
So if you are-- if you would like to for certain
products, procedures, or databases-- you would
like to adhere to a standard and basically
see what other-- how other people try to solve
the problem you're
struggling with, this might be a great point
to start, basically, looking for standards
that are already developed in a
particular field that you're interested in.
OK, so let's talk a little bit how different
standards at academia are.
Quite often, standards in academia come from
a sort of bottom-up way.
Rarely, we have these organizations that are
basically imposing a standard on everyone
else.
It's quite often a few developers-- that's
actually how NIFTI was coming around-- that
see the need for a
better exchange of information and less error-prone
ways of transferring metadata.
And quite often the standards are developed
with a specific project in mind.
So for example-- which is very good.
They are there to solve a particular problem
for a particular project, which is good in
a way that it is driven by a
practical use case.
But it's a little bit more limited, because
often those problems are constrained or limited
by
time, by grants, by a particular specific
flavor of this problem in this particular,
specific project.
An open fMRI, for example-- a repository of
imaging data I've been involved with-- had
the same thing.
They
needed to have some sort of formalized way
of storing data, and they just came up with
something for that
particular project without involving broader
community or negotiations or any consensus
building.
And that's
perfectly fine.
And this comes from the broader incentive
structure in academia, where you basically
are rewarded
for solving particular, specific problems,
rather than building consensus or brother
collaboration.
Standards academia also tend to be technically
simple, because-- especially in biomedical
imaging, quite often
you have a mix of different levels of technical
expertise, and that has to be accounted for.
And therefore standards
need to be, basically, simpler, so people
whose expertise lies more in the biology could
also benefit from using
them and not require getting a CS degree to
start building and working on top of a particular
standard.
And sometimes standards tend to be competitive
in academia.
So it is a bit unfortunate that the way scientists
are
rewarded it is for making particular neural
findings.
And quite often that leads to competitiveness.
And that leads
to a particular group trying to do something
before another group.
And the reward only goes to the first person
that does something.
And that's why sometimes we do see some fights
between standards, and we are seeing
those fights being fueled by basically the
incentive structure and how people are rewarded
through grants.
And then we also see the same benefits as
with standardization effort.
When a particular standard gets widely
adopted, there are great benefits, because
suddenly we can combine different tools and
different-- sorry, different
software tools because they start talking
with the same language.
So an example of that is Nifty and neuroimaging
research.
This is a imaging file format, which is very
widely
adopted right now, even-- despite some of
its shortcomings.
But because it's implemented in so many different
neuroimaging-- research neuroimaging pieces
of software, we are able to mix and match
them and build optimal
pipelines by picking and choosing algorithms
from different sources.
So this is great, and this is something that
basically applies both in academia and in
the industry.
When we all start talking the same language,
there are
great benefits to come.
OK, so after this brief introduction-- I would
like to talk about the practical use case,
and this is something that I'm
a bit more knowledgeable about because it's
a movement I've been spearheading.
It's basically an attempt to
standardize how we describe and annotate research
human neuroimaging data.
And I will try to make it-- make
some broader points because I fully understand
that many of you are coming from different
subfields of clinical
research and not necessarily interested in
the brain and imaging.
But I feel that there are some take-home
messages from this attempt that could be applied
to different subfields.
And maybe some of you will be engaged
in standardization effort and different academic
subfields in the future.
And maybe some of this advice would be
useful for you.
So let me give you some introduction.
First of all, and I think it's important for
any project you start-- is to think
about your goals.
So what are you actually trying to solve,
because it's so easy to go into the nitty-gritty
details
and start solving technical puzzles and forget
about the particular big-picture problem that
you are actually tasked
to solve.
So we wanted to enable reuse of research neuroimaging
data, and we wanted to make this applicable
both to data shared within a lab and between
labs.
So the stress here is on the reuse of data,
so this is not just describing data for the
sake of having a complete
description of it.
And this is having in mind the actual application,
the fact that someone generates a data set,
and
someone else takes this data set and tries
to extract knowledge from it.
And this-- again, this applies both within
a
lab and between labs.
So even if you were to start adhering to standards
in your lab alone, that gives you benefits,
because it's easier to collaborate within
this lab with your peers.
But it's also easier if you're in a higher
position.
For example, you're a PI, it's easier to move
one person from a project to another or basically
reuse some
historical data acquired in your lab for a
new project.
We also wanted to enable automatic analysis
of data sets.
So when you have enough metadata, and they
are all
formally described, that allows you to run
analysis automatically.
And you can start with small use cases, when
it
just pre-processed that data in an automatic
way, and you extract the metadata.
And this is much less error
prone.
But the big-picture vision is that we will
be able to go from data to actual knowledge
through semantic
knowledge in an automatic way, if we have
good standards for describing the data itself.
And then finally, we'd like to have tools
for checking consistency of data sets.
And this is-- this is important in
context of data-sharing, where you're receiving
data from different sides and different groups.
And you want to
basically validate them relatively quickly
and in an automatic way.
And you also need to think about the players,
so
you need to have in mind the people that you're
building this for.
And this will be very important later on when
you
decide what groups to actually contact, and
who are the key players for this thing to
be successful?
So we wanted this to be useful for lab PIs,
and they said this is not just reducing errors
and data handling but also,
very importantly, enable reuse of data within
your own lab.
And might sound a bit weird that I'm stressing
out
[INAUDIBLE] within a lab use case, but with
this project, we had to find this perceived
notion that this is only useful
if you are planning to share data publicly
or widely.
And this is not the case.
It's a separate orthogonal issue, which
I'm happy to talk to any of you at length
later.
But standardization help, whether you are
willing to share data
publicly or not.
And then we have to talk about pipeline developers.
Those are the people who build tools for processing
data, so
they know very well which pieces of methods
are necessary to be able to process the data.
And then finally
databases and repositories-- so those are
both developers of the software, so curators
and managers of these
resources-- and because that enables automatic
data submission.
And they know very well what pieces of method
they are ask for, and they have been dealing
with a broad variety of data sets.
OK, and just to drive home that message of
reuse within your own lab, I usually-- when
talking to a new audience
about the standard-- I present this hypothetical
situation of Professor Smith, who's up and
coming researcher, that
is running her own lab.
And she just came up with a new way of reusing
old data that hasn't acquired in her lab a
while ago.
And she remembers that this data was acquired
by a particular PhD student, who already graduated.
And unfortunately the student, Mike, decided
to become a business analyst or a data scientist
in other words in
California.
And he's completely unreachable, and there's
no way to get him involved in this project.
And Professor Smith is trying to make sense
out of her own data, the data that was acquired
in her own lab, but is
struggling with getting lost with this, because
she found eventually this external hard drive
lying around
somewhere.
And it's a heap of incomplete DICOMs and Excel
spreadsheets.
So this is basically the use case
we're trying to avoid, even within the single
lab space.
So moving on we also try to acknowledge what
makes such endeavors successful.
And many of these things that
we learn on the job-- but hopefully some of
these will apply to future standardization
projects.
Really wanted to
involve broad scientific community.
And that basically means that you have to
step outside of the bubble of your
own lab.
This is the essence of standardization.
You need to find the common language.
So if you only speak to
people who are just next to you, that is much
easier, but that doesn't enable this long-range
communication.
And
here the concept of distance is much more
abstract.
So that means talking to different labs and
talking to different
researchers, even those that you would normally
not actually interact with, and trying to
figure out what are their
needs?
What are their experimental procedures?
So on and so forth.
And then sharing the credit of this work is
very important.
That's one of the big changes or differences
from
building standards in an industry and academia
is that-- and the industry usually have those
panels where
different companies would send their employees
to participate and make things work and find
the consensus.
And
so basically I have employees that are paid
to work on the standard.
In academia, this is a little bit different.
And
usually working towards standardization is
not something that is rewarded by the same
academic means.
So
that's why it's very important to share the
credit of the work of a standard.
So it means that you have to be truly
collaborative and acknowledge all of the individuals
that were involved in the standard in the
way that is respecting
academia, so I'm talking here about authorships
of papers and other products.
Then focusing on the use cases is extremely
important so--
Hello, everyone.
This is Jack Van Horn.
We're going to try and get Chris unmuted here
in just a second.
Hang on
just one moment.
Hang on just one second folks.
We're going to try and get Chris back here
in a second.
OK, can you hear me now?
Yes, we can Chris.
Thanks.
Sorry for that [? demo-nitis, ?] I guess.
So I will assume that I got cut out at 9:33.
Well that's-- well, anyway, the
same slide.
So back on track.
So focusing on the use cases, this is what
I was talking about.
It's basically having in mind the
practical uses of the standard in the future.
And that's why it's very important to get
involved all these people that
will be reusing that data or building tools
to reuse the data involved in this.
Then you have to make the process
public and also document all of your calls
for comments and different outreach operations.
And that basically gives
your effort much more validity.
And then we try to follow this 80/20 rule.
And this is basically-- oh, sorry, this basically
means that we are focusing
on 80% of the most common cases, instead of
spending 80% of the time on the tail of 20%
of the cases that are
least common.
And in other words, we basically don't want
the strive for perfection to prevent us from
delivering
something that is good.
And this is something that you have to remind
yourself over and over again when dealing
with these things, because quite often it's
easy to be overwhelmed by the amount of details
and amount of edge
cases that you have to cover.
And that can slow things down actually to
a halt.
So that's something that is
important.
And finally provide tools.
So the standard itself, if you don't provide
any tools, is just a long, boring document
but
was important to be able to help people adhere
to this standard, as to provide validators.
And this is something
that the World Wide Web Consortium excelled
very-- in a great degree.
They have validators for their markups
down there, and that allows developers writing
websites to check whether what they have written
adheres to the
standard.
And I think that's very important to have
for any standard.
And then community.
It's extremely important to basically build
a community around your effort to make all
devices
feel heard and have a healthy conversation
about different things.
You have to remember, all these people will
be
donating their free time to this effort, so
it's very important to make them feel appreciated
as well.
And building
community is probably the hardest thing about
coming up with standards in academia, but
it's also the most
important aspect.
And on the topic of community, you might be
asking how do I get people involved?
How do I get more people
involved?
And there are some practical, technical things
that you can do to make that happen.
For example, you
should strive to ease the barrier to provide
feedback.
So in other words you're gonna have some draft
documents.
You're going to have some proposals, some
ideas.
And those ideas need to mature, and you need
to have as
much feedback from the community as possible
to be able to turn this imperfect idea to
something that is much
more usable and capture perspectives outside
their own bubble.
So practically here we wanted to make it easy
for people to communicate.
We decided for an old-school mailing
list, because a lot of experts in the field
are very accustomed with this way of exchanging
ideas.
But you also went
for an alternative to that we follow in parallel,
which is an online Google document, that is
open for everyone and
anyone to comment, even anonymously.
And that's a great way because you can just
send a link to this
document, and I can actually show you how
this works right now.
You can send a link to this document.
And they can basically, immediately, not only
have a look at the currentworking
version of the standard, but they can also
immediately say-- sorry, they can immediately
say what they
think about it.
So in other words, they can go here, and they
can start commenting on the format as it is.
And as
you can see there are plenty of people that
already left their comment-- as soon as this
loads-- and this is a quick
way of getting feedback from the community
that is outside of the mailing list, and also
provides ways to give
direct suggestions to the wording of particular
definitions, for example.
And then on the topic of credit, it's very
important to list all the contributors by
name if they are willing to do so and
acknowledge all types of contributions.
So there's going to be plenty of work with
any standard.
And some of it is
documentation.
Some of it is building examples.
Some of it is building tools.
And acknowledging all of this hard
volunteer work is very important to make a
thriving community.
And also induces a feeling of shared ownership.
And this is something very important, because
people should know that this is a collaborative
product.
This is
something that only came about because of
a lot of dedication from many people.
And then it's important to organize in-person
meetings.
Some things are just much better done when
you meet
face-to-face.
And some discussions can go really badly only
because they're done over email.
And finally be
persistent, because most people will be too
busy to help you out to begin with.
And a lot of people will be skeptical
in the beginning, because no one knows if
your idea in this particular standardization
product you're working on
actually is going to be picked up-- is going
to become a standard.
Until it's widely adopted, it's just a proposal,
so
people don't know if they should dedicate
time to it in the beginning.
So lots of patience.
So briefly what is BIDS in more detail?
I'm going to skim through this, and it's a
way of structuring, annotating, and
organizing data.
So in other words, it's not just a set of
definitions of metadata fields, but it's also
how particular
files should be named and organized in a particular
storage space.
And this sounds-- might sound a little bit
backwards to some people, especially in the
age of object stars.
But we found that this is something that a
lot of
labs already do.
And that particular approach was driven by
the community need.
Standards basically describes binary imaging
data, as well as demographic data for participants
and scans.
And
for that we use TSV files, we use Nifty files,
previously mentioned, for imaging data.
And then JSON for other
metadata and all of these fields are well
defined in the specification itself.
I'm not going to go too much into the
details of BIDS itself, because I would like
the messages here to be much more general,
but I want to talk a little
bit about the tools that are important for
making BIDS happen.
And obviously there will be APIs, and there
are APIs being built for BIDS that allow you
to query those data set
programmatically in various languages, such
as Python or Matlab.
And that's important tooling that makes
adoption easier.
That is very important.
But at the same time the standard itself has
to be easy enough for those
tools to be built quickly and easily.
In other words, you cannot build all of these
APIs for all of the languages
yourself.
So you should not rely on the fact that everyone
interacting with the data, described using
a standard,
has to use your tool.
And then converters-- there's a lot of idiosyncrasies
and the data that needs to be converted to
the standard.
And
that's why converters are extremely important.
And finally validators-- and I cannot stress
it enough, the role of the
BIDS validator is very important.
It basically allows you-- and I will attempt
to demonstrate this right now.
It allows
you to, on your own machine, point to the
folder on your hard drive with the data set.
And it performs validation of
the data set client side.
There's no data shared.
This is all in the browser using JavaScript
but without any data
transfer.
And it shows you what sort of errors, what
sort of missing metadata pieces there are
in your data set.
And that takes you from reading a boring specification
to actually adhering to a standard much quicker.
And then we have a process for creating extensions.
That's another important aspect of standardization--
is that
this is always a live document, so always
will be extensions.
And it follows a standard procedure that is
similar in
IEEE and World Wide Web Consortium, where
there are trust, there experts involved, there
are calls for public
comments.
And then you create examples, and we extend
the validator.
And we strive for a consensus to-- before
we merge it.
And we are very big on backwards compatibility,
especially because there are so many tools
building
on it right now.
And many of these extensions are being driven
by certain individuals that can pick up the
role of a chairs of the
subcommittees.
And I just want to list some of them here.
Cyril Pernet, Melanie Ganz, and Dora Hermes,
Tal
Yarkoni are working on some of these extensions.
And there are many others not listed here.
And some of these
extensions actually lead to independent academic
products.
So for example extending BIDS to MEG has been
described as a paper that is currently under
review.
And this is work driven by Galomar Niso from
McGill.
But to wrap it up, because I feel that time
is running out, I want to talk a little bit
about the use cases enabled by
BIDS, because standardization is all great
just to have a language to talk to each other.
But what cool new things
can we actually do when we have this standardization.
And one of the things that we started doing
very early on is
trying to build a standard-- sorry, containerized
applications for doing data processing that
can take a
standardized BIDS data set.
So this is a concept kind of similar to what
you have on your phone.
When you install an app on your phone, you
are never worried about dependencies or other
software that this app relies on.
So you marry this concept, which
is called software containers, with taking
standardized inputs as-- sorry, taking standardized
datasets as inputs.
So that allows us to create a set of [INAUDIBLE]
processing applications that require minimal
metadata inputs and
allow you to very quickly test and also in
a very reproducible way different analysis
and different pipelines on your
data set, as long as it is in the standard
way.
And the other thing that we also did marrying
different aspects of these concepts is that
we've created a free
online platform for sharing an analysis of
neuroimaging data.
And this platform builds on many of the components
that I already spoke about.
But the important take-home message here is
that the components such as the
validator, such as the BIDS apps, are all
independent.
And they are basic building blocks that other
people can
use to incorporate this into their own systems
and services and website and tools.
And I think that's an important
thing to emulate, because that-- again, this
is not about a single lab, this is not about
a particular set of individuals.
You're trying to build an ecosystem.
And to do this right you have to make your
components and tools reusable.
All right, so going back to open neural, this
is a web platform that uses BIDS apps and
uses BIDS to make datasharing,
data analysis, easier.
So basically it allows users to upload data
sets to this website, OpenNeuro.org.
And
then again the validator-- exactly the same
code base I showed you before-- is being run
before you upload the
data, so you know if there are any errors
that you have to correct before actually committing
to a long data
transfer process.
And then it allows you to basically-- when
you upload your data set and create a snapshot
of it, it allows you to
choose from a library of different BIDS apps
or basically containerized data processing
pipelines, and you can
schedule a job running those BIDS apps in
the cloud that is managed by this website.
And this is basically how you
can schedule the job and select different
subjects.
And when you press Submit, you're going to
get an email after
the job is finished, and you can go and explore
results of such analysis.
And I can show you before we move on a
little bit how such analysis actually looks
like.
So here we are on OpenNeuro.
And I uploaded my own brain, because vanity,
I guess.
No, it's because I can
actually, clearly share my own brain dataset
and other project.
And basically as you can see I can go to different
data sets and look at different parts of the
website.
And we have both public and private data sets.
But let me just
go to my very own data.
And after a moment, I can show you actually
the jobs as they're finished.
For some reason, the internet is acting up
today a little bit.
And I'm not quite sure-- OK, there we go.
So I run a set
of different apps on this particular data
set.
And for example here, this is ANTs cortical
thickness app-- would
finish and succeeded.
I can go through the logs, and I can also
look or download through the results.
And for
example, one of the outputs of this particular
pipeline is this image of the brain segmentation.
And when it loads,
you're basically going to see how well ANTs,
which is a particular piece of software for
doing structural and
functional brain coregistration and segmentation,
worked out on this data set.
So, yes, this is how this works.
And just to wrap up, I would like to thank
many or all of the contributors to BIDS
and the BIDS ecosystems.
You can see, it's a long and growing names,
long and growing list of names and
institutions that contributed in different
ways to this effort.
And we hope that this list is going to grow
even more,
and we're going to make even better standards.
I also compiled a list of resources that you
can have a look if you want to learn a little
bit more about the things
that I talked about today.
And that includes the IEEE and W3C processes,
as well as a history of DICOM, and
some of the BIDS stuff that I talked about.
And I guess this is all from me.
And I believe that we have some time to
take questions.
Chris, thank you so much for that really great
overview of the need for standards and why
we need to have them
from a practical standpoint and some of the
sociological issues, as well some of these--
providing some of these
resources for us.
One question that I guess I have is very often,
you'll see where there's a new standard that's
being announced, and there's some group someplace
that says oh, we've decided that there needs
to be a
standard.
And we've anointed ourselves as the standard
creators, and we're going to make the standard.
And
you'll all love it.
It'll be great.
You should want it.
As an end user, how can one be comfortable
with this-- almost this barrage of standards
development and
knowing which one is the most trustworthy?
Or is it needed?
And do I make the leap to change the way I
do my
own data standardization, or rather what form
I put my data in?
How do I know when is the time to do this,
and
how do I know to trust the people who are
saying that oh, we've developed this standard,
and it's great?
You
should adopt it.
How do I know?
Well, such an easy question to start with.
Yeah, of course I'm kidding.
It's an incredibly hard problem.
So the
telltale sign is adoption, but that's a chicken
and egg game, because someone has to be the
first one to do it.
So
the other thing that you can go with is seeing
which individuals or which organizations are
actually involved in this
process, and if there is a process, if there
actually has been a broad communication about
how this has been
developed.
But at the end of the day, everyone adopting
something new is taking a risk, because it
might be good
or might not be.
So there are ways to minimize that risk.
If you are-- it's probably good to commit
with a smaller
project, maybe delegate it for a new RA collecting
a new data set and gather some information
this way, rather
than committing a whole consortium to it to
begin with.
But, yes, this is the struggle.
And that's why-- especially in the early days
of BIDS-- we struggled to get people
involved, because they were hesitant, because
they didn't know if this thing's going to
pick up or not.
Well, I guess everybody has a finite energy
that they can devote to things.
And if it looks like they have to do a
whole scale-- a transformation of the way
they organize their data or storage or what
have you, that I don't know--
for some people that might be a horrifying
thought.
One thing they might be thinking is that well,
wait a minute.
Here's some new standard.
Is this based on something I already know?
So for example one of our listeners is asking
is the data set description based on the HCLS,
W3C data set
description?
And somebody may say oh, I'm familiar with
that, so OK this makes sense to me.
And that might
lower their barrier.
On the other hand, if it's-- I'm not speaking
about BIDS in particular, but if people weren't
familiar with that, they may say well, wait
a minute.
Why would I go and do this, because it seems
to be
unattached to anything else that I might be
familiar with?
Is there any sociological barrier there?
Yeah, totally.
And I think that what is important here is
that they totally agree with that-- those
links that building on
existing solutions is very important.
But it's also important to acknowledge that
different communities will respect
and acknowledge or actually be familiar with
different existing solutions.
So for example there are some unwritten
practices in the way that people organize
their data in academic labs, that they are
familiar with.
There is the
imaging data storage format called NIFTI that
a lot of people are familiar with.
And there are some excellent
standardization approaches of data in the
industry that academics might not be familiar
with.
So it's not only
building on things that are already there
but also acknowledging what your community
is familiar with, and what
building on things that are already there
but also acknowledging what your community
is familiar with, and what
they're gonna basically take advantage of.
And how big of a role do, say, journals play
in this?
And well there's a lot of interesting sociology
regarding that,
which we don't need to get into-- about for-profit
or open science or bioarchive or what have
you.
But journals play
an important role here in that they're publishing
the research.
Do they have any sort of-- I don't know what
your
experience has been-- have they had any sort
of buy-in to the acceptance of standards in
support of the literature
that they publish, so that the data that's
contained in them is more easily reproducible?
Yes, so in a way, it was rather indirect.
And there were two aspects where journals
actually contributed to this.
One was when we were trying to publish the
standard itself as a paper.
They've pushed that in the right direction
to be more transparent about all the things
that we did to reach out to the community.
And I think that was very
important and emphasized what we knew already.
But it's better to make this all transparent.
And the other aspect how journals are involved
in this is there's this new breed of journals
that publish data.
So
those are data journals in other words.
I'm talking about scientific data here, Data
in Brief.
Frontiers is doing that.
Neuroinformatics is doing that.
There are specialized data journals for social
sciences and psychology as well.
And those journals, since they publish data,
or data descriptors, they care a lot about
the consistency and the
reusability of those data sets.
And they usually offload the burden of data--
over indirect.
As for example, there are
a few journals that would recommend repositories
that adhere to standards.
But they wouldn't recommend
standards themselves.
So this is how journals basically play a role
in this.
Right, well, we're at the top of the hour
now.
And I'd like to thank you, Chris, for providing
this great overview of
data description standards for biomedicine.
A perfect addition to our collection of webinars
in the Guide to the
Fundamentals of Data Science.
I'd like to thank everybody for joining in.
Once again, thanking Chris and do look
forward to a future of our Guide to the Fundamentals
of Data Science Webinars.
And watch your email for further
announcements about those.
Wonderful.
Thank you very much.
Everybody have a wonderful day and a great
weekend.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.